welcome to this video playing Marco from
Germany so Kings Indian it's one of
those rather solid but usually not very
exciting queen for openings the Tory
attack just playing some standard
developing moose anyway to make it a bit
more interesting add sometimes the
problem if you are black here and you're
saying I can really start doing much
then you try to do something like this
and it blows up in your face but ok I
want to be a bit enterprising let's see
maybe we should be five is an idea
you have a name let's check right Steve
Austria that's fun I didn't even know
that he's on the ICC never played him
cool that someone from my not directing
my neighborhood neighborhood but not far
away in my area
yeah but should be five was a good move
g5 was a blow it wasn't a very
successful idea yeah night age 54 draw I
can let's do that once and see what he's
doing okay i will definitely deviate oh
is this a draw after Bishop to e3 no it
isn't right let's let's play something I
don't want to draw it I just wanted to
reevaluate a g5 was a nonsensical idea
it really just weakens my position for
no particular benefit you have five but
ESP shall be to thy go 97 Queen g3 it's
not helping much
he's got 93 m possibly Bishop b2 even
attacking my d5 pawn maybe this one
trying to get get the pawn back quickly
OS cup before okay Queen a3 just at
least Ricky okay it's at least a little
bit tricky this pollution a g5 was a
really [ __ ] idea i mean how bad was
that yeah sometimes if you think okay
well this is kind of boring and you try
to make it interesting you only make it
interesting for the other guy now should
have just played some some normal stuff
yes this looks that looks very
problematic okay Bishop b5 or this idea
Bishop b5 I guess um maybe rook da does
bishop c7 even 95 maybe man it can take
take d5 okay
now move the night he always has Bishop
b5
what can you do not much
I'm angling for 94 maybe maybe I can
play 94 at the right moment try to play
on c3 let me think for one moment
they're like you so something like ticks
takes 92 that's night term 91 e 5 this G
form now let's prepare that II 5
yeah what why this really champ just a
pawn up don't don't see any particular
compensation
yeah that is possible I wasn't sure
about it Bishop f7 order capture a cheek
at night is six King King somewhere who
takes on th I don't get it back ok I am
giving away e7 now put him at playing in
the scanner it's kind of strange it's
not taking it
I have no squares them be 59 f5 running
right into pins time Morning Joe quite
depressing
I need a square badly even if it's not
really a nice position
yeah maybe I get in if I've somehow even
if it costs a pawn okay see I bishop at
five ok I want to be active don't don't
sit around right five maybe we'll see
three or can do this he's got the check
on f5 but it's lost anyway so check
doesn't really matter that much need
some kind of activity Knight f3 check
rook takes you three I mean this looks
at least like some kind of pseudo
threats
um let's keep that show at five Bishop
g5 maybe I have some kind of idea now
stick it check check check check I have
no time whatsoever check
check check check okay come on girl
offer Sherlock actually rented to reside
instead of offering a job Ichabod as 40
ians five or something ugh come on I
know what a bad game yeah it wasn't that
was a bad idea to make it interesting
there in the opening g5 that was rubbish
I was really rubbish this is kind of
this kind of thing here yeah you don't
you don't get a decent position you have
it there with the queen is with that
King side we can so much yeah and I
should probably not gamble anymore with
the capture and play play c4 or
something maybe this kind of thing I
don't know and now this it still looks
awkward with g5 and there wasn't a good
idea yeah and here the thing is I'm just
not getting the palm back just not
getting it back yeah this wasn't a
particularly great idea either Jim I'm
just this porn down neither 597 I was
already very strong but ok I'm he's just
this material up and even though I mean
maybe I had some kind of swindling
chance with this slightly open King word
it was always lost yeah that I couldn't
I couldn't really come come back from
this weekend a week opening play that I
that I put on the board there that was
really too bad okay well thanks for
watching